i was doing um mix cd so i was
bootlegging everybody else [ __ ] bro me
too that's how i got my name bootleg kev
literally i was just [ __ ] burning cds
and i had taken them to the party yeah i
had the two cds all the dual the
gangster grill
everything the southern smokes
everything all the gm radios i had a
folder
with the each mixtape cover i just took
a little uh you can find it online
yeah print it out yeah and then put all
them shits in like this binder and [ __ ]
no i would go i do it i would go to and
i'd have like eight versions of the cds
stacked on top of each other right
behind that album and i was taking i
literally wasn't even like you wouldn't
even get the cdk sometimes you just get
here's the cd
get a piece of paper i used to go to
office magic
with all this stuff like put that in
right now like you got no case put it in
right now though
that's so crazy
i used to i used to like go on the
message boards and download all the
mixtapes and [ __ ] and albums
bear [ __ ] yeah
and then uh
i'd hit office max and buy the slim
jewel cases i had a little bootleg i
used to go shoplift the ink did you get
the color the color coordinated yeah the
cases yeah yeah the yellow but like you
know i had i had like i like i used to
print all the all the covers off yeah my
little cheap-ass printer and i would go
steal the ink because if the ink was
[ __ ] mama expensive
i'd steal the ink cartridges out of the
demo printers at the store
and then school you can do them and then
i printed it print the covers and then
i'd be at the swap meet every weekend
slang and mixtapes man
and dvds too
man
do you remember what the best seller was
that was me cleaning them printers out
what's the best seller like like do you
remember which artist or which product
college dropout wow i've never sold so
many of one project for me it was uh i
used i probably i've sold hundreds of
game the documentary album the
documentary did well too the documentary
was moving boy but i was i was big on
mix cds i always had
at least like 25 requests
well i used to do that too or somebody
would would give you a list and i'd be
like cool 20 bucks i'll go make the cd
for you exactly see he was charging way
more i should have charged that much my
kids and my i would charge five bucks
per mix tape at the swap meet five bucks
but if you wanted a custom mix it was a
dub
so if like let's say i should have did
that yeah my custom my custom mix was
like it was like 10 bucks now i'd be
like yo you could get this cause i was
really running them i was really running
them dudes you could get this new dj
drama mixtape or whoever is mixtape uh
but if you want me to put some [ __ ]
together for you it's twenty dollars
yeah but the 20 was really for the you
know what i'm saying for your time party
no your party favor like it wasn't oh i
see i see it
so the 20 was for the eighth that's what
i said like i was born that and then it
was like
nice 25 balls 30 balls coming yeah each
time we dealing with a customer you know
what i'm saying we killed two birds one
stone but i'm getting my project out
there that's how i felt about it like
i'm getting my music out there like but
what was crazy was people really was
rocking with it